the allegations of chaos and
backstabbing in the administration and
nothing new it's been the centerpiece of
several other books the difference here
is the reporting and the reporter Bob
Woodward is one of the most legendary
and credential journalists in the United
States and when he says that the
president's chief of staff called Trump
an idiot or the defense secretary said
the president was like a child that
carries journalistic weight now both men
have refuted these statements and Trump
has said that the entire book is a work
of fiction but fear is out now and the
dirty laundry is out there for the world
to see people in this bookstore have
been snapping up the book starting
immediately at midnight and everyone
can't wait to get their hands on a copy
unless of course you're a trump
supporter and that is exactly who my
equator wanted to hear from in the
run-up to the books release she met with
some Trump supporters in Washington the
Trump International Hotel is an island
of refuge for this meeting of Trump
supporters and the otherwise extremely
Democrat Lucy of Washington DC people
here can bask in their mutual love of
the President and ignore negative media
like say a certain book by a certain
legendary journalist as Bob Woodward's
book hits the shelves it's already
created waves among the president's
detractors but for Trump supporters this
is simply more negative media coverage
another day of fake news for president
that they still very staunchly support
it's a left-wing attack getting ready
for the elections to try to energize
that side of the of the populous there's
been so many books out but that's not
gonna stop Donald Trump supporters we're
very loyal to him because at the end of
the day you know who we get if we don't
get down a track we get left wing
snowflake nuts he's not your average
politician he's trying to fix things
he's coming in from the outside and the
establishment does not like that on both
sides of the aisle especially on the
left so I don't even I don't even bother
to I'm not gonna bother reading that
garbage even members of Congress are
jumping on the bandwagon to discredit
the two-time Pulitzer Prize winner and
his reporting
he's a lifelong liberal he is he may be
a journalist but he has a bias he has an
approach if you look at his his four
decades of work you're gonna find that
he if he picked somebody he picked
somebody to attack there was a
Republican and not a Democrat and you
know if you have four decades you should
have some of both he doesn't the
allegations of a morality cronyism and
lying contained in Woodward's book mean
nothing here
these Trump supporters have only good
words for their president
[Music]